I’ve been married
for almost 50 years.
So, my wife knows what
it’s like to be a writer,
and she also knows what
it’s like to be a writer’s wife.
I really wanted to say
something about how
a long-term marriage creates
its own Boo’ya Moon.
People outside that
marriage don’t see in to it.
Any couple who’s been together
for a long period of time,
has an understanding of each
other that’s deeply private.
I don’t think narratives
usually focus on
the person that is
next to that author
and how that person
has a very huge impact.
This show tries and
aims to be there
and understand and
connect with that world.
Stephen King marries both
epic and intimate really beautifully.
Wow.
I never talk about my childhood.
How bad was it?
Pretty damn bad.